the movie opens up in space on January
12th 2011 when three astronauts named
Brian Jos Cinda and Marcus are up there
to fix a satellite as they're engrossed
in work the spaceship suddenly
experiences a failure and all the
electronics shut down at the same time
Marcus notices something strange a weird
Black Metallic swarm coming at them
really fast unfortunately before Marcus
and Brian can take action the Swarm
crashes into their spaceship this
Collision knocks out jinda while Marcus
is flung into space Brian tries to grab
him but the spaceship's pull on his
tether stops him and Marcus drifts away
into space panicked Brian goes back into
the spaceship and tries to contact
Marcus but the systems are broken
meanwhile the strange swarm creature
drills a hole into a lunar crater and
continues its descent after that Brian
looks at jinda who is unconscious and he
decides to take the spaceship back to
Earth he successfully stabilizes the
shuttle and despite having no power
manages to start a stock Thruster this
creates enough energy to land the
shuttle safely on Earth upon their
arrival Brian is labeled a hero for
landing a powerless spaceship the
science doesn't really check out on that
but this is a big dumb movie about the
moon falling out of the sky so he's a
hero however as the years pass by
officials start suspecting that he was
the one responsible for the disaster No
One Believes his theory about the black
swarm attack either to make matters
worse jinda can't back up his story
because she was unconscious throughout
the incident she thinks maybe it was a
solar flare or a meteor that hit their
spaceship at last NASA concludes that it
was a mistake on Brian's part so they
fire him from his position the story
then fast forwards 10 years and we meet
casy Housman a janitor at the University
of California while working Casey often
sneaks into Professor offices to use
their computers he likes to play Neopets
and visit e-bombs world one day he logs
into the Chile National Observatory
system and finds out that the Moon is
getting closer to Earth this worries him
so he tries has to contact NASA but no
one takes him seriously in the next
scene jenda is called to work early in
the morning at Nasa she checks on her
son Jimmy and gives instructions to his
Nanny Michelle before going to the Space
Center there she learns that the moon's
orbit has indeed changed and their
satellite has detected strange energy
coming from a hole in a lunar crater
jend is shocked by the Revelation and
decides to act quickly on the matter
back to KC he's frustrated with not
getting through on the phone so he heads
back to the professor's office to
conduct more research while he's going
through a newspaper he learns about an
event called astronaut day happening at
the local Museum boy that's lazy writing
realizing that this may be his only
chance to find someone useful Casey
prints out his research and drives to
the museum coincidentally the main
speaker at the event is none other than
Brian when the two meet casy wastes no
time and explains about the moon's
changing orbit however Brian doesn't
believe him where'd you hear that one of
your professor's computers and instead
calls security to remove him from the
museum as he's being taken away Casey
scatters his papers hoping that Brian
will read them later later in the
evening Brian learns that his son
Sunny this writing has been arrested by
the police here it is revealed that
after he got fired from NASA he spiraled
into depression and lost his home his
wife also divorced him and took custody
of their only son the next day he goes
to Sunny's trial determined to make
things right however Brian only ends up
causing a commotion by interrupting the
judge and making up stories to defend
his son this leads to the trial being
post ped and sunny is kept in jail until
the next hearing meanwhile jenda and her
team discover that the Moon is getting
closer to Earth and will break apart
soon with city-sized pieces crashing
into our planet they also see a hole in
the moon which is a sign that time is
running out not long after news of the
moon's Collision threat spreads on
social media the person who leaked This
Confidential info is none other than KC
as he got tired of waiting for NASA to
act in the next scene Jos cenda and her
senior Albert hold a press conference to
explain the situation they assure the
public that everything is under control
however this announcement isn't enough
to stop the chaos as people begin
overcrowding the stores to stock up on
supplies toilet paper and eggs everybody
you know the drill at the same time NASA
holds a meeting and decides to observe
the Moon by sending astronauts to space
after a day of preparation they manage
to assemble three experienced astronauts
later the shuttle arrives at the moon's
atmosphere and hovers itself above the
crater but as soon as the astronauts
send a probe into the moon's hole the
same strange black swarm from earlier
shows up it attacks the shuttle and
kills all the astronauts jenda and her
colleagues witness everything on their
screen ends are taken aback meanwhile
the situation in big cities is
deteriorating millions of people are
leaving their homes in hopes of finding
safer locations Brian also finally gets
to know about the danger he then
remembers KC trying to convey the same
thing long before anyone else knew about
it hence he starts looking for
information about the man soon Brian
tracks Down Casey at a restaurant and
asks him how he knows so much about the
moon I was just playing Roblox on my
prof's PC and it popped up the latter
shares that he has spent years studying
distant planets and looking for huge
structures in our solar system as the
two are engaged in conversation suddenly
there's a change in the moon's gravity
this causes violent tsunamis and
earthquakes on Earth the restaurant also
gets engulfed by a tsunami but our
heroes somehow manage to survive back at
Nasa Jos cinda's boss Albert realizes
that they can do nothing about the
situation so he quits his position and
rushes off to a safe location this
leaves Jos Cinda in charge of the entire
organization to find more about the
black swarm she checks video archives
from Brian's suit during their mission
in 2011 Why did no one do that before
shockingly she discovers that Brian was
indeed telling the truth the video
clearly shows the black swarm attacking
the spaceship but for some reason NASA
decided to keep this information hidden
from the public after this jenda
immediately conducts a meeting with the
military and they consider using nuclear
weapons on the moon however she believes
that there's no no way to fix the moon's
orbit without destroying it she then
contacts her ex-husband major Doug to
talk about an electromagnetic pulse or
EMP called Zulu x-ray 7 which might help
them destroy the mysterious black
entities and bring the moon back to its
orbit Doug who is working in the
military agrees to help but only if she
and her son Jimmy join him after the
mission yeah fine I'll help you save the
world but but only if I get to see those
sweet legs again next jenda figures out
that she needs to go to the Moon to find
out what's really going on and she wants
Brian to go with her he is the right
person because he's the only one who has
seen the black swarm and has the ability
to operate the shuttle even in A Worn
Out condition that night a military
helicopter comes to take Brian but he
agrees to go only if KC can come with
him this movie has a logic score of ne5
next they meet jinda who tries to
explain things that they already know
she shows them a video of the Swarm
attacking the astronauts and says it's
made up of different AI powerered
nanotechnology Brian agrees to help on
one condition his son Sunny must be
released from jail and brought to the
evacuation spot for safety once they
agree they got an old shuttle from a
museum to carry the EMP right then Earth
starts experiencing violent earthquakes
and volcanic eruptions this is strange
because the moon's gravity isn't strong
enough to cause these things it supports
KC's idea that the Moon is a hollow Mega
structure sadly an earthquake damages
the shuttle at their base and with a
missing engine they can't launch but
while everyone else gives up KC keeps
working on calcul ation for the launch
they eventually realized that when the
moon is right over Earth its gravity is
almost as strong as Earth's is and if
they launch at that exact time they can
use the moon's gravity to compensate for
the damaged engine yeah following this
the trio groups up and quickly
formulates a plan Brian will fly the
shuttle jenda will be the guide and casy
will use his calculator for before
they take off Casey calls his mother
while jenda and Brian say goodbye to
their respective sons who will be
meeting Doug Brian even gives Sunny a
gun for protection ction Brian is
unhinged as they get ready to launch a
big gravity wave hits the base causing
widespread destruction the seawaves come
close to the shuttle but Brian manages
to use the moon's gravity to make a
narrow Escape after a few minutes as the
shuttle approaches the moon they turn
off all their electronic devices Brian
then uses the thrusters manually even
though they encounter debris along the
way back on Earth the weather is going
haywire because the Moon is very near
it's also raining debris and some of
them are the size of a building to avoid
all this Michelle and the boys have to
take shelter in a flimsy Shack until
it's safe who needs a flimsy Shack when
you've got plot armor on the other hand
when the shuttle nears the moon Brian
takes a Rover with the EMP and sets it
up his bait for the black swarm
unfortunately the Swarm completely
ignores the Rover and instead goes after
the shuttle Brian assumes the Rover's
remote control might be what's
attracting them so he destroys it but
the Swarm keeps approaching at a rapid
Pace just when it seems like the shuttle
is about to be engulfed Brian figures
out that Casey's phone is is the source
so he gets rid of it even though KC is a
millennial nerd he somehow doesn't freak
out about this this finally dissuades
the Swarm and they go away now the group
will have to guide the shuttle into the
moon and they only have 2 hours to do it
before the military launches their nukes
I'll swear after all the crazy weather
settles down Michelle and the boys
continue their Journey but they soon
reach a dead end with angry residents
pointing their guns at them fortunately
Sunny's stepdad Tom spots them and takes
them away back at the moon the shuttle
carefully enters the mysterious Cole now
entering the moon's anus when they reach
a certain point they discover that
Casey's idea was right the Moon is a
mega structure around a power core the
AI powered nanotechnology swarm is the
one absorbing the power and trying to
break down the moon at this moment the
trio gets ready to use the EMP against
the Swarm but something unexpected
happens the shuttle starts moving by
itself the Swarm almost gets them but a
door opens and the light guides the
shuttle inside unfortunately the landing
is a bumpy one and the shuttle ends up
getting wrecked as the group lies there
unconscious a mysterious light scans
them back on Earth the military loses
patience and decides to launch the
nuclear missles because of this Doug
calls his son and gives him the bad news
that they can't go to the bunker anymore
at this point oxygen is quickly
depleting from the air so sunny and the
others are forced to wear oxygen masks
they then continue their journey to find
a safe place if there is one on the moon
jenda and Casey wake up and are
surprised to find that they can breathe
and there's gravity but Brian appears to
be missing suddenly a door at the end of
the room opens Casey is skeptical about
entering but jinda thinks that someone
is trying to help them Brian on the
other hand is talking to a friendly
being he wakes up in a strange room with
white light and it shows him information
through images taking the form of Sunny
this being reveals that it's an
operating system OS created by ancient
humans a long time ago when they had
advanced technology and peace it further
discloses that the Swarm is an AI That
was supposed to help humans but it
became so intelligent that it developed
its own thinking and killed its creators
alron and the Terminator have nothing on
the moon's butthole bugs the OS then
tells Brian that to beat the Swarm they
need to lead it away from the moon's
core and destroy it this way the moon
can finally go back to its orbit after a
while jenda and Casey locate Brian
inside the room and help him get up the
team then regroups and finds their
damaged shuttle fixed and ready to go
they decide to try one last time to deal
with the Swarm Brian is even willing to
sacrifice himself for the sake of man
kind in the next scene the group Powers
up their shuttle and flies away from the
Moon with the AI swarm following them
relentlessly though Brian made it clear
that he would be the one to make this
sacrifice KC secretly grabs EMP and
releases himself from the shuttle he
then leads the Swarm to a safe location
and detonates the EMP killing them all
that's it good job Sam with this
sacrifice the moon finally begins moving
to its original spot science Brian
and jenda also managed to use a pod to
get back to Earth safely and the final
scene Casey's Consciousness is put into
the moon's base and the OS talks to him
it takes the form of his mother and says
that they have an important mission to
begin the hell was what why did NASA
hide the videos of the
AI subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching